bourg madame monsieur bonsoir pour la
troisième fois en un an le département
du vaucluse a été durement éprouvée la
nuit dernière par les orages
une heure de pluie sur des terres
gorgées d'eau résultat beaucoup de
dégâts puis de 2000 sinistrés et de mort
c'est à bollène que les inondations ont
été les plus spectaculaires
reportage anne consignes et
jean-françois giorgetti la barque avec
l'hélicoptère c'est le seul moyen qui
reste quand il y à deux mètres d'eau
quand les hommes à pied et les camions
ne passent plus mais attention aux
courants créé par lou s'engouffrant dans
les ruelles
il est parfois terribles
dès avant la levée du jour des
évacuations préventives avaient été
effectués sur bollène mais toute la
matinée les pompiers ont vérifié que
personne n'était en danger dans cette
voiture par exemple
après vérification la voiture était vide
soulagement messieurs ont pas vous
demander ce que vous venez de faire la
maligne et ça m'a pas semblé enfin je
vais pas remonter au sexe et sa belle
mère bien propre à mal de bébé aussi là
bas on va voir ce qu'on peut faire plus
près de la rive du fleuve là où le
courant était trop dangereux pour les
barques c'est à l'hélicoptère qu'il a
fallu recourir dans la matinée jusqu'à
sept appareils ont survolé la zone en
milieu de journée ce fut le tour de
l'hopital 80 malades pour la plupart des
personnes âgées transférés vers d'autres
établissements de la région
et puis dans les zones encore inondées
il a fallu porter l'échelle à des
sinistrés parfois choqué
tout ça les met en place en moins sont à
paris alors et savez c'est pas ma race
cet après midi bollène était comme
envahi par une armée de balais d'oracle
et et de pelles tout le monde s'y est
mis
on a eu pas mal de dégâts mais là les
autres on a eu beaucoup plus que nous
alors on les aime né vers 17 heures le
quartier s'est brusquement vider panique
les pompiers craignent la rupture de la
berge du fleuve à rivière au mans
c'est vrai dans l'après midi le niveau
du lez à remonter cette fois les berges
ont tenu mais on redoute les pluies
annoncées pour la nuit prochaine